There's a new "menace on our streets," and
it's helping people manage their pain, it's
all over Facebook, and everyone from moms
to addicts love it…
Kratom.
Film at 11.
What up peeps, this is DNews, I'm Trace.
The interesting thing about what is "legal"
or "illegal" is that in order for something
to be illegal there has to be a law made against
it.
If there's no law forbidding something, then
it is not, technically, illegal!
A 'new' drug named kratom has grabbed headlines,
as the U.S. Drug Enforcement Agency decided
to add the plant to it's list of Schedule
I (one) drugs, effectively banning it as an
"imminent hazard to public safety," with "no
medicinal use."
But many would argue against that last part especially.
Let's look at the science.
Firstly, we have to know what this stuff is.
Kratom's science name is 'mitragyna speciosa'
(mit-rah-jyna).
It's a tree native to Southeast Asia, and
its leaves were traditionally brewed into
tea for social and religious ceremonies, or
chewed as a stimulant to boost productivity
and combat fatigue for farm workers.
In fact, in a 2012 study of the northern states
of Malaysia, 88 percent of people reported
daily use.
Medicinally, outside of Southeast Asia, it's
used to wean morphine-dependent patients and
as an opium substitute.
Mitragyna speciosa can be a basic stimulant
in small doses (resembling cocaine or amphetamines),
but becomes a sedative or narcotic at larger
doses (resembling opiates like morphine).
At high doses is can cause "sedation, euphoria,
and a possible dreamlike state."
In addition to chewing or brewing, the leaves
are available as a pill or powder.
There are over 25 substances in the plant's
leaves, but a study in Addiction Biology detailed
the effects of two unique psychoactive components:
mitragynine and 7-hydroxy-mitragynine.
The first, mitragynine -- is a psychoactive
alkaloid: the component that gets into the
brain and works similar to other alkaloids
like morphine, ephedrine, quinine, and nicotine;
tripping some receptors in the brain known
to respond to opioids.
The second, 7-hydroxy-mitragynine, is "less
abundant" and behaves more as an analgesic
(or painkiller).
It was found to have an acute ability to reduce
anxiety (when dosed correctly).
Unfortunately for some, kratom is also habit
forming; with withdrawal manifesting both
physically and mentally.
In fact, part of the reason the DEA added
it to Schedule I  was because of a study
of long-term users, finding most chewed the
leaves for an average of 18-and-a-half years,
causing anorexia, weight loss, insomnia, skin
darkening, dry mouth, frequent urination,
and constipation -- and that's just the USE
of it.
The withdrawal starts 6-12 hours after use
and causes tremors, anxiety, joint and muscle
aches and limb jerks, mood swings, hostility,
aggression, depression, insomnia, sweating,
nausea, and headaches…The DEA even observed
symptoms of psychosis: delusions, hallucinations
and confusion.
This is a pretty serious situation, and can
last up to 10 days.
The consumption of the plant itself doesn't
appear to be deadly at "normal" doses, but
reports have shown overdosing can cause seizures,
coma, and death.
In fact, the DEA cited 15 kratom-related deaths
from 2014 to 2016.
But even if you're not overdosing, studies
have shown use of kratom can lead to permanent
brain changes, causing cognitive impairment,
and difficulty recalling memories.
The Biomed Research Journal dug deep into
kratom and stated simply, though it's often
marketed as a "natural" alternative to opiates,
[quote] "kratom is not a safe drug."
In an interview with Scientific American,
a specialist on the topic said, "Heroin was
once marketed as a therapeutic product and
later was criminalized," but "[Kratom] is
just like any other opioid that has abuse
liability."
All that being said, it may still have medicinal
use, but with Schedule I we may never know;
because researchers might never try to study
it.
When it comes to substances like this, it's
not whether they're safe or not, or medicinal
or not, it's how they fall on the spectrum
of legality that determines their availability.
Whether the DEAs call to make it illegal is
"right" can be debated, but the "safe" or
"natural" claims are pretty silly.
It can be damaging, and opiates come from
plants too, though they're not often called
"natural."
It would seem at low doses, mitragyna speciosa
could be okay, but it could also be highly
habit forming, dangerous and even deadly.
Obviously, more research is needed to see
if this plant offers alternatives for opiates,
but for now, we'll have to wait and see if
science keeps on truckin.
[SPONSOR/AD READ]
When we do scripts like this I always feel
like I'm ruining people's day… but some
people revel in that.
. If you're one of those people you should
check out Discovery GO and you can watch airplane
repo.
Watch that and any other discovery show on
the Discovery GO app.
You can download free at your App Store
If you're worried about which drugs are dangerous
-- like weed or cocaine which is "worse" -- we've
got the answer for you here.
How do you feel about kratom?
I assume there are a bunch of people angry
already, I see you Libertarians!